the jurgen experience you know as a
sober guy
there's part of me that wishes because i
liked him i liked
mushrooms but only like once or twice a
year because it's so [ __ ] fun and you
get like you said you get all that stuff
going
yeah but um i did them last week part
how was it did you laugh a lot
because all i did was post malone and i
did a podcast we did mushrooms
oh my god yeah we had a good old time
how how long how long were you tripping
uh well the podcast was four hours long
and we were drinking too so it was like
just madness it was all just like
mushrooms i could feel the mushrooms and
i was getting high too he wasn't smoking
pot but we were drinking bud lights and
it was a lot of chaos this is like
exactly what my 80s were like
i but i i think about people go and do
ayahuasca and do those those
i that really appeals to me that's
different in that
you know you could call it a drug but
it's dmt which is what ayahuasca
brings up right that's what it was the
active ingredient
you're still you you're not drunk that's
what's weird about it
well i don't know what it is but if you
wanted to get real woo-woo you would
call it some sort of a chemical gateway
into another dimension
or to a another realm that you can't
access without it
it doesn't seem like a drug but how is
it not any different than
i got stoned and i saw crazy [ __ ] well
first of all it's endogenous
right so your brain actually has this
chemical inside of it it's one of the
more interesting things about this drug
is that
your body knows how to process it so
well like if you do coke right
like i'm sure you you're coked up for a
long time right your body's all [ __ ]
up for a long time
dimethyltryptamine only lasts like 15
minutes what yeah your body recognizes
what it is so it brings you back to
baseline very very quickly
so if you do this yeah it's a 15 minute
experience
yeah the ayahuasca takes longer because
ayahuasca is an orally active version of
it so what ayahuasca is
is the roots of one plant and the leaves
of the other so you have dmt in one
plant and in the other plant you have
something called an mao inhibitor
mao is monoamine oxidase and that's
produced by your gut to break down
dimethyltryptamine and a bunch of other
chemicals but it breaks down
dimethyltryptamine because
dimethyltrypta means in a bunch of
different plants
so you will you could trip just eating
filarus grass
if you didn't have monoamine oxidase in
your gut so
when you eat this gra if you ate the
grass nothing would happen because your
body would break it down
but if you had an mao inhibitor then you
would trip balls
well and then the other thing that
people talk about with
is like i vomited for five hours yeah
that's the problem with ayahuasca you're
gonna
blow your [ __ ] out you're gonna
diarrhea throw up it's disgusting stuff
you know i don't wanna do that it's also
because you're getting the plant
you're getting all the the stuff that's
you know not the active ingredient from
these roots and these leaves too
and then also your body's freaking out
what did you have have you ever had any
um awakening or vision or i've had a lot
of visions on
to dimethyltryptamine yeah anything that
you could that you
once you got um once you were done
tripping
that didn't seem like the ramblings of a
madman or was just something you were
like oh wow i had a i had a revelation
it's hard to say um that they all seem
impossible to describe to anybody else
other than people that have experienced
it but what what it does make you
realize is that
how the the thing that i always felt
when i came back
is like how is this possible that you
could
go to a place like this where you could
see something that's way more vivid and
way more powerful than regular life like
whatever it is
it's not it's it's not like it's
it's dull and confusing and you feel
drugged and you feel less you know you
feel more
you see more it's more vibrant it's more
powerful
and whatever is over there seems to know
you it seems to understand it seems to
be you're communicating with something
something that's far more intelligent
than you
far more advanced and not hindered by
all of the things that we're hindered by
like our egos and our
our our nonsense our insecurities and
our civilization and culture it's like
it's it's some sort of other kind of
consciousness
you know and and in in it and they joke
about
things they they make fun of you like
one time i did it and uh all these
gestures
like this uh like a a
geometric pattern of gestures like a
fractal
like infinite gestures were giving me
the finger like this
[ __ ] you like mocking me
and the message that i got was that i
was taking myself too seriously
like maybe even like wow like my
intentions going into the trip i was
taking myself too seriously
and i remember relaxing on oh okay
and they're like that's right like
they're nodding their head
like yes like it was a message like
hey stupid you know you take yourself
too seriously [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you i like [ __ ] gestures like
with a hat and everything so
in your life now like let's say you
are stressing out about something it's
very seriously do the fractal just
gestures do you remember them and go oh
yeah i had this
very very you know i mean like like it
you bring something back that you can
practically use in your your this
dimension this time
humility there's a there's a humility
that comes from real psychedelic
experience is that you just because you
know that they are possible
it's it makes you it makes you second
guess the significance of regular
existence
because it seems like that whatever that
like that might be where you go when you
die
okay i was waiting for the i was waiting
for the moment
i was waiting for the moment so you know
if that's what it is
[Applause]